Mình nghĩ trong sốc tình thần ra cách tạo nên ra chị, tôi đó rồi với chức nó sẽ tự đến.
Mình như thế này nhỏ, hãy là chỉ cần một khám chức thôi.
Mình chưa được ở sạy hiện, mình chưa hiểu dạng, không phải là cái thứ gì nó cũng trong cái cường xác của mình đâu.
Không phải là thứ gì, mình cứ hết lòng.
Mình cứ hát tâm của mình thì là mọi thứ sẽ ra là cho mình đúng cái gì đâu.
Nói khai phụ thuật và rất là nhiều đối tổ khác.
Và đến nếu như nó không như mình vắng hỗi thì cũng chỉ là mọi thứ của mình.
Chỉ là một đối tổ đó mà mọi thứ nó chưa lộ, thì mình sẽ xác sắp nận hơn.
Mình sẽ phải là hôm nay mình đi xác ngoài đuổi, có thể là một chuyện tỡ là cho mình không thể buổi.
Mình thì mình thì mình cũng thì một ngày cũng mình không thể cho phói nữa.
Không còn lặng mình nữa.
Thì nó như vừa rồi, cho nghĩ rằng là mình đã chựa thành hơn.
Mong rằng là, cứ mỗi năm, cho qua mình sẽ chỉ có cập thể mắng yệu hơn soại thành hơn.
Chứ không có thể có thể là người khác thì mình thình thông.
Nhưng bạn thân mình sẽ thông phải thình thông.
Châu nghĩ rằng là mình có thình thông, bởi vì sau bà hơn năm, mình là việc mình být dành là yêu thương.
Nhưng là chăm sóc cho cải tin thành của mình.
Thì để là các suy nhất để cho mình rồi có nhiều dạ chí hơn nữa.
Và khi mà có nhiều dạ chí thì vẫn chắc tự nền.
Con đường như mà châu lưu luôn chắc chắc là việc là a thành công là con nhiều vất chắc.
Thì cho nghĩ rằng là mình sẽ không có ngày bị còn lạc, đó tin thành.
Lấy là suy nghĩ của châu.
Bự cạnh ngày đầu tiên.
Mình vẫn nhịt với đều vậy, mình vẫn chú chắc cái tin thành của mình như vậy.
Nhịt cái mấy mắn, nó sẽ để vấy mình.
Châu phải thay dùng với từ rất tiên của mình, hẹn gửi thành phật và xinh thành về nó.